the Prime Minister insists this is it
the only deal on the table the only plan
available but that proposition will soon
be put to the test in the meaningful
vote to guarantee that her agreement
with Brussels gets the backing of
Parliament Teresa may needs 320 MPs to
vote for it but here's the problem this
column here shows the number of MPs who
are currently saying they can back the
deal this bottom column shows the number
of MPs for all different parties who say
that they cannot now over the course of
the next week there will be all sorts of
efforts to try and shift some of these
numbers but if things don't change
Theresa May is facing near certain
defeats the Prime Minister might try and
seek further concessions from the EU and
present a revised plan to MPs but a
whole range of different scenarios could
also unfold if the vote is lost there is
a chance conservative MPs might bring a
motion of no-confidence in mrs. Mays
leadership but an earlier effort to get
the required 48 letters fell short and
now some who did submit a letter appear
less bullish for reason I wrote the
letter to gran brady was because it
became apparent that the Prime Minister
was unwilling to move away from her
present position now if she loses the
vote next week but I hope but then she
will move away another possibility is
that opposition parties join together to
bring a motion of no confidence in the
government as a whole to try and force a
general election if Labour make this
move it would likely need the backing of
the DUP to succeed but it seems other
opposition parties will get behind it so
long as other options are left open if
there is a confidence in the government
after that we will vote against the
government the SNP has no confidence in
this incompetent shambolic government
but we will also look to be part of a
majority around alternatives to the
Prime Minister's deal one of those
alternatives could be a second
referendum a cross-party group of MPs
have now delivered a petition to Downing
Street signed by over a million people
demanding a final sale brexit the
government now accepts that
a referendum people's vote is now very
likely that's remaining in the European
Union is now one of the very firm
options on the table the government's
accepted that and I think there's a lot
of movement in the country and a
duration but there is of course another
very real possibility leaving without a
deal at all unless there's a majority in
parliament for an alternative or a delay
that is what will happen by default in
march next year in that case this whole
agreement every article and protocol
within it would be meaningless and so
the upcoming vote is anything but Tom
Rainer Sky News in Westminster
and if you want to know how your local
MP feels about Teresa Mays brick city
we'll take a look at this interactive
graphic it's on the Sky News app and
website sets out the full brexit picture
at Westminster and how the vote may pan
out